JULIA SILGE: OK, let's get
started with this model
monitoring example.
So I'm going to open up a new R
Markdown file from a template.
So I've got all these
different templates
from the packages I
have installed here.
And I am going to
use a Flex Dashboard.
I really like the
Flex Dashboard package
for a lot of
different situations,
like making really pretty
shiny apps without much effort.
Two, dashboards I don't
want to use Shiny with,
but I want like a dashboard
kind of situation.
So that's what we're
going to use here.
So I am going to--
let me save it.
I'm going to call it
this monitor.RMD here.
And then the title--
so I'm going to--
this is going to be
a dashboard for monitoring
a model for traffic crashes.
So the data here, the
data in the model,
predict the probability that
a crash involves an injury.
It's crashes that are
in the city of Chicago
and the data comes from
the city of Chicago
and we have all this information
about what the crashes are like
and then we predict whether
the crash involved an injury.
So Flex Dashboard, we
have all these different--
it is a very flexible tool.
You can do columns or rows.
I am going to
actually change this
out and make this the
storyboard mode here,
which is pretty nice.
And then it turns
out that almost all
of the logic for
the model monitoring
is going to go here
in the setup chunk.
So we're going to have a really
big setup chunk with lots
of code, and then
actually less code down
to create the dashboard itself.
And when it's time
to monitor something,
I think it's nice to kind of
make clear in your head what
are the pieces that you need.
And so one piece that
you need is your model.
So your model is
deployed somewhere.
In this case, it's a model
that I already trained.
I have another video that
shows how I trained it.
It's deployed using a plumber
API on RStudio Connect.
But really, that model
could be anywhere.
You just need to be able to get
to it from R, which, of course,
we have tons of options
for being able to do that.
And then you need to
get your new data.
So the new data that's
coming in that you
want to be able to see how is my
model doing with this new data.
And then your metrics,
you know, the metrics
that you had back
at the testing time
and then the metrics that we
would measure over time as we
continue to move forward.
So these are the pieces
that we need to get going.
Let us talk about how
to get these things.
So to get the data,
often the easiest thing
is just to go back to when
you trained the model.
This is the GitHub repo where
I have all the code I used
to train the model originally.
And so let's just go to the
beginning of that whole script
and get the code that I
used to train the model.
But instead of getting
two years of data,
let's just get
two weeks of data.
What will happen is as I run
this dashboard week after week
after week, it will get
newer and newer crashes
as time passes.
So let's run this and
make sure it works.
So what this is doing is
going to the city of Chicago,
getting the new
crash data, and we
have the information about
the weather condition,
the trafficway type
and whatnot, and then
whether there was
an injury or not.
So that's one piece,
we need the new data.
The next piece we need
is we need the model.
So to handle the model, we're
going to use the httr package,
we're going to use jsonlite.
The model, in this case,
is deployed as a plumber
API on RStudio Connect.
It doesn't have to
be this way, right?
Like, wherever your
model is published,
you can go and
get it from there.
But this is how I'm going to
do it here to demonstrate.
So this model has
a predict endpoint.
It's got a metrics endpoint
that are the testing
metrics that we expect to see.
So I'm going to
copy this URL here.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to set up a post call, and
I am going to send as the body,
I'm going to-- it's this crash.
This crash data is
what I'm going to send.
But I need to make it to json--
oh, you know what, I don't
think I've loaded these yet.
There we go.
OK, so to JSON.
And I'm going to do--
I'm going to send
the crash, I'm not
going to send the
injuries, though.
And then-- so that would
give me the result.
And then I want
the text as UTF-8.
And that will be
JSON at that point.
So I'm going to do fromJSON.
So these are
predictions like so.
Like that.
So let's run this.
So these now are
our predictions.
So it's sending for all of
those new crashes that I have,
that I want to use for
monitoring, it's sending them
to the model, getting
predictions for them,
and then handling all of the
output here and getting back.
So what we have
at the end there--
let me do it like this--
is a vector.
Like this.
So it's a vector.
And these are probabilities
of having injuries.
We have our new crash
data, we have our model,
and then let's put it
together and find our metrics.
So we take that crash
data and let's find on--
let's call it pred_insjuries.
So we just bind
that on together.
So now we have a column of
predicted probabilities.
Let's make a-- let's make
a column of hard class--
hard class predictions.
So if this thing that I just
made is greater than 0.5,
let's call it injuries.
And if it's not,
let's call it none.
So this now matches these.
So I'm making a hard
class prediction.
I think I need to say if
anything is a character,
I need to change it to a factor.
Right.
There we go.
OK.
So because the function
that I'm about to use
needs factors and
those functions
are from the Yardstick package.
So the yardstick package
is from tidymodels.
And you can use it
with models that
have been trained
with tidymodels
or you can use it with
any other kinds of models
and get out these nice results.
Actually, before I started
working for RStudio
or using tidymodels
at all, I used--
Yardstick was actually the first
part of this whole ecosystem
that I used at all
because it is so nice.
And so we can do metrics.
And the way we do it is we say,
the true value is in injuries.
And then we can say
predicted and pred_injuries,
so that it's the
hard class and then
the class probabilities
like this,
and it gives us accuracy, ROC.
And you look at this,
you're like, is this bad?
Is this worse than what
we expect based on how
the things did at testing?
This is what we want to know.
We probably want to
do a little bit more
because this is for
that whole two weeks.
And we probably want to add
a little bit more in here
and say, mutate--
so we've got to--
what's it called?
crash_date.
So we want to do a little
bit of some rounding here.
Actually, let's do floor_date.
Say, as.date, crash_date.
And then we're going to
say unit equals week.
So now we're
rounding by the week
that we have and
then we're just going
to group by that crash-date.
Like this.
So now we have it
for these-- we've
got three beginnings of
weeks in this data set.
So we have these
different values here.
So these are the metrics_by_week
like this that we have.
And if we are starting
out our model metrics,
let's say, we just trained our
model and we are starting out,
we would probably take this.
Let's say, we train our
model on March 20th.
We would start this and
it would be time for us
to start keeping track of this.
And I think the a great way to
do this is the pins package.
I'm using the
development version
of pins as of this recording.
It will go to CRAN soon.
But if you see me use some
of the functions and things,
they might look a
little different
than what's on CRAN right
now, but those functions
will go there soon.
And so what we want
to do is I actually
have some stored metrics
in a pin right now.
And so I'm going to
show you how to get them
and then how to rewrite them.
But if you were
starting from scratch,
you would just start by
writing without reading first.
The way that this
works is, let's say,
I have to register a board,
somewhere to store things.
So in pins, you can
have a board on azure,
you can have a board on--
gosh, there's so many--
there's on Google Cloud
Storage, on GitHub, on Kaggle.
There's all these different kind
of boards that you can have.
I'm going to show how to use
a board on RStudio Connect.
So my server is the same thing
as where my model is deployed.
Here.
And then I need my key.
Sys.
And it is stored in
my .renviron file.
So I'm getting it out
of there with this here.
It's a pretty nice
place to store things.
So I think if I type out
board here, it'll be like,
it's a pinboard on
our RStudio Connect
and here are all the things
that are stored there.
Like, for my co-workers,
RStudio, all these things.
And I have something
stored there too.
If I do pin_read, it's called--
can I spell my own name?
I don't know.
julia.silge and it's
called traffic-crash-metrics.
And if I read that, I can say--
let's call it old_metrics,
like this.
So I'm reading the
old metrics here.
So I've actually been monitoring
this model for a while now.
But so I've been like,
monitoring, monitoring,
monitoring.
And so now what
I can do is I can
combine the old metrics
with the new metrics
and then write it back.
So I think the way to do this--
old_metrics.
So I'm going to do like a filter
that this crash_date isn't it.
Like that.
And then just bind
them together.
So this is kind of
a nice way to do it
so that you don't end up
overwriting things and all
that kind of thing.
OK, so if I do
this, there we go.
So I have taken my old metrics,
I have added on anything
that I have that's new.
Yeah.
So I can-- maybe I should
arrange it so it's the same.
Metric, crash_date, like that.
There we go.
And so I can write this back.
So we have our old
metrics, my new--
the metrics by week, and
let's call that new_metrics,
like this.
And then I can
take my board and I
can write to it my new metrics.
So I have to say where
do I want to write it to.
So I want to write it to
that same pin, like that.
And so it's writing back up.
So what a pin gets you is
versioned ways to write things
back and forth, which I think
is really super duper nice
because you can always go back.
You can also pin inversion
models themselves.
It's really useful
for model monitoring.
OK, so, look at that
chunk, it's enormous.
So much is going on in it.
But this is like, we have our
new data, we have our model,
we have our metrics.
And so now, let's just
make a few visualizations.
So I think for the
storyboard, I'm just
going to put like different--
a few things here.
So let's, for example,
say, model metrics here.
And then we'll put this,
we'll say, like, new_metrics,
because that was all of it.
And let's say, what do we have?
The new metrics.
new_metrics.
There is a bunch--
there were several different
kinds of metrics in there.
So let's just do two, filter
metric and accuracy, roc_auc.
And we can make a--
say, do a crash_date
estimate like this.
And then we can put
a geom_line, like so.
And we'll say, aes color
equals metric, like that.
And I think that will need
a facet_wrap by metric.
Let's say, free_y.
and I think this will look
better if it's like they're
on top of each other like this.
I think that looks pretty good.
So we'll do something like this.
And then, oh, yeah, so, I'm
going to use Plotly to do this.
So let's save this as p and then
let's do ggplotlyp, like this.
So we'll need to also load
library plotly, like so.
Let's see what that looks like.
Right.
Whoops.
No, it's a source.
That's so silly.
It's called plotly, right, which
I put there, which is right.
OK.
OK?
All right.
And I think we can do--
if I do it like this, if I
save it here as an object
and then I do hide_legend p.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
Nice.
OK.
So that's pretty good, right?
Like this is our metric.
I can spend more time
and make this nicer.
x equals NULL.
I mean, I can
definitely keep going
and like make this nicer
in so many different ways,
but this is pretty good.
So model metrics, I can go on.
I can-- I'm just going to
say, like, I could do--
I can make a map, I
could make a table.
There are so many different
things I could do.
And then I can--
if when I hit Knit--
let's see if this works.
It's going to go
through now and it's
going to do all the stuff in the
setup chunk, which, remember,
calls two different APIs,
computes all the metrics,
does all this kind
of stuff, and then it
should pop out a
dashboard here for me.
So let's talk about what you
might do with this dashboard.
So let's look at this here.
OK, so what might you
do with this dashboard?
So this dashboard
does not use Shiny.
And we can put more
narrative in this place
and maybe we put our other
things that we would have here.
So a dashboard like this,
what I would do with it is I
would publish it somewhere where
I could update it once a week,
in this case, right?
And then be able to look
at it whenever I wanted to.
I have this published
in the example
that we can show you on RStudio
Connect, which, of course, has
these great feature of
where I can schedule
it to run on RStudio
Connect once a week,
send me a nice email
saying that it succeeded,
and send me a plot and
all this kind of thing.
But if you publish your
RMarkdown documents
in a different
way, you can pursue
that in whatever way is
appropriate to your own data
infrastructure.
What I want you to
take as a takeaway here
is that model monitoring
requires you to think
about what are the
pieces that are required,
that are important to you,
your model, your data.
And then there are components
of the R ecosystem today
that lets you move forward with
the kind of model monitoring
that you need to do.